[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et dans les Landes il y avait plus de
800 agriculteurs qui ont manifesté dans
les rues de Mont-de-Marsan regardez
[Musique]
alors président et secrétaire général
David et Frédéric du syndicat à
l'origine de l'appel nationale à la
mobilisation de ce mardi la fdse1 vous
étiez sur place à Nîmes lors de la
manifestation toujours les mêmes
revendications est-ce que ça bouge pas
non non c'est malheureusement toujours
les mêmes revendications et alors je
sais pas si on aura le temps de tout
développer parce qu'effectivement il
faudrait des missions complètes
donc je vous le dépense de plus en plus
on dit j'ai beaucoup de collègues à vous
aussi qui nous l'ont demandé on pense de
plus en plus à la faire donc je pense
que ça va arriver et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui pour résumer pour tous les
Français qui nous regardent ça fait des
années et moi que je vois des
agriculteurs qui viennent dans mes
émissions et j'ai l'impression que ça
fait des années j'ai les premiers que
j'ai reçu cette lettre il y a 5-6 ans
j'ai l'impression que ça bouge toujours
pas donc c'est le cas aussi non mais
c'est ça
c'est pour ça qu'on arrive à des
exaspérations comme ça quoi je crois
qu'il y a un vrai mal-être du monde
agricole malheureusement on vient de
subir une série de crises climatiques le
gel la sécheresse bon je parle pas des
autres crises aussi les crises
climatiques en plus les crises qu'on a
tous
exactement
lever comme on dit on est stigmatisé et
ça devrait être dans le patrimoine parce
qu'il peut pas y avoir de gastronomie
samedi non mais elle est viticulteurs
les agriculteurs les et je vais vous
dire tout tous les métiers les éleveurs
les éleveurs où on voit aujourd'hui
c'est devenu impossible on voit des gars
je vous le dis je le redis qui travaille
15 heures par jour et qui arrive même
pas à dégager 1000 euros par mois donc
c'est ça
le plus important aujourd'hui comment tu
veux qu'un agriculteur il dise à ses
enfants tu vas faire agriculteur comme
moi les mecs qui veulent plus être
agriculteurs on va se retrouver dans
quelques années tu auras plus un
agriculteurs c'est ça aussi moins 50 %
disant tout simplement mais parce que
c'est vrai que je vous dis et tous les
jours tous les jours qui passent c'est
des agriculteurs qui en aura le bol et
qui vont qui ferment le qui ferme qui
fait qui qui qui arrête le métier il y a
aucun agriculteur je vous le dis qu'il y
a son fils bah tu vas reprendre la ferme
où tu vas reprendre l'exploitation parce
qu'ils disent et les enfants se disent
bah j'ai pas envie de la voir la même
vie que papa parce que parce que je vois
ce qui se voit comme c'est compliqué et
c'est vrai que aujourd'hui non seulement
c'est un métier qui faisait rêver avant
vraiment c'est vrai qu'ils étaient rêvé
on avait envie d'être agriculteurs ils
étaient respectés on savait qu'on avait
c'était le premier masser les premiers
maillons de la chaîne et derrière on
voit qu'aujourd'hui si on a plus le
premier maillon de la chaîne je sais
c'est c'est nous qui allons tous
empathie et il y a une urgence et
qu'aujourd'hui je le vois on sait que ça
ça bouge pas du tout non on a un souci
parce qu'en plus derrière c'est plus de
produits importés avec effectivement des
méthodes qui sont décriées en France je
peux pas de problème
c'est que vous ne travaillez vous n'êtes
pas n'est pas tous les mêmes règles pas
tous avec les mêmes armes c'est à dire
que aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
français ne peuvent pas travailler avec
les mêmes arbres que les agriculteurs
allemands ou d'autres pays donc
forcément quand un moment il y a un
déséquilibre
dès le début comment vous voulez faire
pour être compétitif c'est impossible
nous on a on a malheureusement plein
d'exemples on a l'exemple de la pêche
l'Espagne est arrivé dans dans l'Union
européenne elle a écroulé le marché de
la pêche on faisait 600000 tonnes de
pêche en France aujourd'hui on en
produit 200000 tonnes et la pomme la
Pologne aujourd'hui est entraîne
d'écraser les producteurs français parce
qu'on a fait une Europe mais c'est pas
une Europe sociale il y a des
différences de coûts qui sont énormes
d'un pays à l'autre en Europe en Pologne
il travaille à 3 euros de l'heure nous
ici c'est le SMIC pas que les gens
soient riches évidemment mais ce que je
veux dire c'est que ça fait des
distorsions de concurrence et suite à la
guerre en
Ukraine toutes les pommes de la Pologne
sont revenues sur l'Europe et inondent
de partout et aujourd'hui on a un vrai
problème notamment de pommes par exemple
mais bon on a eu ces problèmes dans
grosse partie de l'agriculture le
problème c'est que si demain j'allais
dire on continue c'est encore plus de
produits d'importation avec des choses
qui sont décriées en France quoi
j'insiste bien les pesticides
j'allais dire voilà tous les toutes les
choses qui disent le problème
ils font une et derrière nous on peut
pas on peut pas faire plein de choses
donc comment tu veux te battre contre
les autres c'est impossible il y avait
déjà cataly il avait dit dans
l'agriculture en Europe tant qu'on va
pas aligner les salaires bien sûr les
agriculteurs ils ont manifesté hier mais
ça fait des mois et des mois qui
manifestent et à un moment là les mecs
il faut prendre il faut que ça il faut
qu'on agisse il faut que voilà il faut
que ça aille un peu plus vite parce que
je vous dis il y a une urgence
et c'est tous les jours que un drame se
joue pour les agriculteurs et c'est nous
c'est vous c'est nous qui allons un
moment le ressentir au jour le jour et
c'est vrai que quand on est agriculteur
qu'on travaille 16 heures par jour et
que je vous dis à la fin du mois comment
j'ai vu des agriculteurs qui me disent
il me reste 500 € 400 € ou rien souvent
même disait rien il me reste rien moi il
me reste rien je travaille 16 heures par
jour il me reste zéro à la fin pourquoi
parce qu'à un moment on vous fait
plaisir à tout le monde donc oui alors
oui l'écologie c'est très important mais
à un moment il faut qu'on se batte avec
les mêmes armes que les autres à un
moment si les agriculteurs français et
bah ils se retrouvent
c'est comme si vous avez joué au foot
vous jouez à 18 contre 11 forcément vous
jouez pas avec les mêmes armes donc
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que vous voulez
tout respecter on est les bons élèves et
au bout du bout c'est nous qui nous
faisons enfler donc à un moment c'est
incroyable puis les grandes marques
David et Frédéric théorique vous
expliquer vraiment
à noter les spectateurs parce que il y a
une vraie vraie urgence
en plus on nous on nous met des
contraintes on a fait je pense depuis 20
ans 20 ans 30 ans tout ce qu'il fallait
faire on a fait notre vignoble on a on
est dans toutes les démarches à
mirrornemental ce soir je veux on est
dans des années département ou le bio
c'est énormément développé et en face de
nous on a
l'état et compagnie au lieu de essayer
de nous aider de nous de nous soutenir
c'est les mesures environnementales qui
vous ont mis aussi dans le dans le dans
le pétrin j'ai envie de dire alors il y
a les mesures environnementales et puis
il y a les folies de l'administration on
en a eu encore une une il y a pas très
longtemps une démonstration il y a une
grande sécheresse l'année passée dans le
département l'État qui s'est rendu
compte que puisque c'est les calamités
agricoles qui nous couvrent ça allait
coûter cher puisque malheureusement ça a
touché une grande partie de la France a
changé trois fois les modes de calcul
pour la sécheresse ce qui fait qu'à la
fin on a 30% du département qui est
exclu de la sécheresse et tout ça c'est
des agriculteurs qui n'auront pas
d'indemnités puisque l'assurance nous
c'est l'assurance d'État ça c'est les
trucs qu'on sait pas et c'est dramatique
je veux dire derrière chaque dossier
alors l'étape pense qu'il a fait une
économie mais c'est une erreur c'est des
gens qui arrêteront qui déposeront le
bilan etc donc c'est des drames humains
derrière bien sûr donc on a une
administration qui est
ubuesque où les gens qu'est-ce qui vous
disent aujourd'hui les agriculteurs
David et Frédéric au quotidien vous êtes
le président et secrétaire général ils
vous disent quoi ils vous dis on veut
arrêter on n'en peux plus c'est ça le
problème là sur les images on voit par
exemple il y a une culture on voit des
oignons ces oignons doux des Cévennes
c'est une très petite culture il y a pas
de
ils ont pas de problème pour revendre
c'est très bien sauf que ils veulent
juste qu'on les laisse travailler qu'on
le laisse voir comprennent pas un arrêté
au mois de juillet et là aujourd'hui les
collègues j'ai beaucoup en survie
d'ailleurs la les gens sont les
aujourd'hui ils savent pas s'ils vont
planter des oignons ils me disent j'ai
les planté je vais faire tout le travail
je vais prendre et je vais tout jeter
alors
deux trois mesures deux trois mesures
exactement
on a voilà
vraiment simplement pour que même les
tous les Français qui nous regardent
comprennent qu'on comprenne nous aussi
voilà concrètement ce qu'il faudrait
faire ce qu'il faudrait vraiment les
pour la première mesure c'est quoi alors
faudrait protéger déjà larguulture
française comment comment parce que un
certain moment comme on vient de le dire
il faut qu'on soit sur les la même
égalité c'est ça comme on dit me
consomment pas et important pas la
l'agriculture qu'on ne veut pas pourquoi
parce que ce qui se passe qu'est-ce qui
se passe avec les autres pays par
rapport à nous voilà par exemple David
mais les autres pays ils ont pas les
mêmes normes c'est ça donc prenez par
exemple si tu es par exemple l'Espagne
pour pas le dire il traite avec des
choses qui sont interdits chez nous
depuis 15 ans c'est ça ok à un moment
donné effectivement vous êtes pas sur
les exactement c'est à dire que nous on
veut on veut tout respecter je vous le
dis on est les bons élèves et à la fin
c'est nous qui on en fait c'est beaucoup
moins cher
donc aujourd'hui comment tu fais les
mecs ils vont acheter des tomates en
Espagne bah voilà bah c'est comme ça ok
un moment je le dis à chaque fois
l'écologie il y a il faut toujours
trouver le bon le bon curseur entre
économie et écologie et là au niveau de
l'agriculture le curseur il est pas bon
là le curseur il est mal placé on est on
est pas dans le bon truc on est on a on
n'a pas la bonne recette je pense que
moi je pose pas l'un et l'autre je pense
que l'un et l'autre peuvent être
compatibles oui mais évidemment avec des
gens qui sont intégristes on est bien
d'accord je crois qu'il a dit Frédéric
depuis des années des efforts énormes
ont été faits voilà l'agriculture quand
on m'en parle et que je vois des fois
sur mon plateau pas forcément là mais
sur d'autres c'est l'agriculture
regardez commentaire je rigole je rigole
non ce que je veux dire c'est
l'agriculture de mon grand-père qu'on me
parle donc il y a un moment donné
j'incite et c'est pour ça que je parlais
tout à l'heure d'une émission touche pas
à mon agriculteur parce que c'est
quelque chose qui mériterait en vrai
débat quoi et vraiment je pense aussi
plus que voilà pense aussi on va on va
la faire on va la faire vraiment
vraiment que non mais c'est vrai
franchement en termes de mesure nous on
est très inquiet aussi sur la hausse de
l'électricité mais moi j'ai vu
malheureusement sur votre plateau
plusieurs mais mes amis boulangers qui
étaient là et qui et qui ont subi cette
eau c'est que dans nous l'idée c'est
surtout de dire il y a pas de
aujourd'hui sur le tarif jaune
électrique il y a pas de bouclier comme
il y a eu jusqu'au tarif bleu donc
beaucoup d'exploitation qui ont des
frigos ou des forages vont tourner avec
du tarif jaune sans tarder et vont
sûrement avoir la même surprise que nos
amis boulanger voilà c'est c'est très
très gros que vous êtes touché vous
c'est à dire partout c'est à dire que
l'électricité ils sont touchés les
intempéries ou la sécheresse vous êtes
touchés donc
ils sont touchés ça veut dire que dans
la gueule
vous vous en pâtissez et les taxes et
tout est à grand pays comme la Chine les
États-Unis mettent des taxes à
l'importation bien sûr comme nous on est
petit on ne le fait pas exactement et du
coup nous on importe sans taxe et eux et
voilà
on ne peut pas s'en sortir l'agriculture
voilà Trump
pour une histoire d'avion et ben
exactement
pour rien et à la fin ça a été un drame
parce que on voit dans la situation
parce qu'on perd des marchés mais pour
les reconquérir c'est très compliqué le
marché que vous avez perdu
et dernier période en plus difficiles
ils le savent qu'entre mesure comme ça
et c'est très bien qui qui flingue la
France c'est sa manière de gérer avec
les petits pays en tout cas on va on va
on va la faire cette émission et puis
sur l'électricité sur le gasoil c'est
quand même l'État c'est vite fait c'est
une grande partie de taxes non mais s'il
veut faire vraiment qui se passe le
ministre s'il veut faire un geste il
peut le faire rapidement
il y a une autre chose aussi qui est
importante il y a deux lois qui ont été
votées qui s'appelle les loisigalim qui
est censé mieux rémunérer les et
malheureusement comme la grande
distribution il y a cinq ou six grands
acheteurs et qu'il y a une multitude de
vendeurs mais vous comprenez bien qu'ils
sont dans une position de force et que
malheureusement aujourd'hui ça continue
alors il y a quelques enseignes j'avais
expliqué je vais pas les nommer mais qui
ont fait quand même un peu d'efforts je
le reconnais par contre on a des
enseignes qui restent toujours très
vorace quoi